done a lot of videos and Alzheimer's
I've talked about
amyloid plaquing I've talked about some
falsified research relating to amylene
placking I talked about the genetic
factor of getting Alzheimer's or putting
that risk by 30 to 50 percent if you
have a very specific it's called an APO
E4 if you have that mutation you're 30
to 50 percent more at risk right and
I've done all these videos as I find
more information but I stumbled on
something that is groundbreaking it's
actually quite amazing and you have to
hear about it the more you understand
the true mechanism of a problem the more
a solution will pop out if you were to
take a match and you're in the woods and
you would light the match
and start the woods and fire would it
help to focus all your energy on putting
out that match
the answer is no you know as a child I
love to play with matches unfortunately
it got me into trouble I remember one
time when I was a really small probably
actually this was last year no I was
eight years old and a friend and I were
um
uh playing with matches and I found some
matches and we went in the back of the
field and
I wanted to see what would happen if I
let a match into this empty bird nest
that was just sitting there there's no
birds in it I just want to see what
would happen
so I light it and fire and my friend
says put her down I said no Let It Go a
little bit longer well within a matter
of seconds it just starts spreading like
crazy we bolted to uh the back of the
neighborhood to someone's house to get
water and then we turn around and the
entire field is on fire okay and so I
had to run home and tell my father that
I lit the field on fire and as he looked
across you can see the neighborhood with
these Flames behind the entire
neighborhood that's spreading to the
next neighborhood and you can imagine
how much trouble I got into and how I
felt but
just my luck it started raining I just I
seem to luck out it started raining and
it put the fire out but that was a scare
I don't know why I told you the story
but it does relate to the match Forest
concept well that's what research has
been doing the last 20 years focusing on
the match okay with very very little
results if any in fact sometimes the
treatment for Alzheimer's is worse it
can actually progress the condition and
so most of the research has been
focusing on this theory that this
amyloid plaquing is this metabolic junk
that shouldn't be there it has no
purpose we should just Target and get
rid of it
well it is true that there's MLA
placking involved in Alzheimer's right
but amyloid plaquing would be equivalent
to that match that starts to fire trying
to wipe out the amyloid plaquing uh is
going to be a waste of your time the
gene that makes this amyloid plaquing
which is kind of this fibrous tissue in
the brain that ends up destroying the
neurons in the brain has been around for
a very very long time like 400 million
years because this Gene is also another
species so why has it been unchanged in
the genetics for this long unless there
was a very important purpose of this
plaquing well incidentally two
researchers which I'm going to put down
below stumbled on something that is just
quite amazing they found out that this
beta blocking is a very potent
anti-microbial peptide a hundred times
more potent than penicillin well let me
first give you some background there's
two parts of the immune system you have
the innate immune system that you're
born with it's the ancient first line of
defense immune system okay part of your
army
and then you acquire this other immune
system it's called the acquired immune
system and that's when you have all the
antibodies and T cells and the B cells
and all these other things and that
usually is delayed it takes time for
your body to develop that okay but in
the brain
there is only the innate immune system
we don't have this other immune system
in the brain because it might maybe
because it's just too powerful it can
create a lot of collateral damage and
the brain is very sensitive so this is
what they found they found that this
amyloid plaquing is really an innate
immune system reaction to a microbe that
seeds or triggers this reaction and so
there's always this kind of this Cascade
between amyloid plaquing and this other
thing called neurofibrillary Tangles
okay so that's a mouthful that basically
if you look at that like fishing line
the plaquing and these Tangles work
together to entrap and contain pathogens
and so when they grab these microbes
right let's say virus they start to
release certain chemicals and one is
bleach yeah bleach and so that just
kills the microbe and then because we
have this reaction okay
we get inflammation in the nerves it's
called neural inflammation and so now we
have all this collateral damage that's
occurring okay and then we basically
it's it's all reacting to dead nerve
cells okay so we have this whole Cascade
thing that's happening Alzheimer's is an
innate immune reaction
to an infection
now usually that infection is not
necessarily a full-blown infection it's
usually a subclinical infection that
tends to brew in the oven this is why
plaquing usually develops over 20 years
and by the time you have the first
symptom you're at the peak of plaquing
okay and then it kind of goes down from
there and so the question is like what
seeds this whole thing what is the
triggers well there are several really
key
pathogens that are associated with
Alzheimer's
you have the herpes simplex one virus
okay that's been known to trigger
Alzheimer's you also have spiral Keats
in Lyme disease you have something else
called climidophilia pneumonia which is
a microbe involved in pneumonia and
there's several others and as far as
someone having this Gene susceptibility
to alzheimer's that said APO E4 which
has a risk between 30 and 50 percent of
getting Alzheimer's apparently if you
have that Gene you're more susceptible
to allowing the herpes virus to cross
the blood-brain barrier into the brain
which explains a lot and so then this
got me thinking isn't there a microbiome
in the brain
and apparently there's been this
long-standing thought that no it's all
sterile just like the blood was sterile
until they found out now it's filled
with microbes well the brain does have a
microbiome that's right and it's there
probably to help protect you okay and
there's a huge relationship between
Alzheimer's and an altered microbiome in
your gut
but people don't talk about the brain
and there's just not a lot of research
with this microbiome what can we do
about it right well
the most important thing is to do
whatever you can to prevent it there's
some other things that are involved in
this as well okay having a strong immune
system having a strong Diversified
microbiome
and also doing whatever you can to fix
insulin resistance which also makes you
very very susceptible I mean over 50 of
the population has insulin resistance
and that alone adds to the fire the
inflammation in the brain not being on
the ketogenic diet
being on too many carbs adds more
inflammation to the brain you want to
run your body on ketones that bypasses
the whole thing and so I think if you
get it in time and you can turn things
around really nice once you have it it's
just more difficult I think you can
improve it it all depends on how much
damage that's there and the other thing
is if you have this genetic weakness
this APO E4 you should definitely not be
drinking alcohol being exposed to
smoking okay you should be exercising
which will help the genes you should be
doing keto you should be eating
extremely healthy things with
antioxidants so some other things to
think about since 95 of the population
has herpes simplex one okay
is to keep that darn virus in remission
as much as you can right do what you can
to keep your body healthy
um because I've noticed people that get
head injuries and go through major
losses and stresses and then develop
Alzheimer's right I think it kind of
just activates
what's already there the herpes a virus
that kind of comes out of our mission
and then just makes things worse so we
have some key factors to look at we have
the epigenetic things you can do right
now okay and I have a lot of data on
this getting enough sleep the exercise
keeping your stress low eating extremely
healthy avoiding chemicals that can
trigger this if you keep your stress
really low and keep your resistance high
with your immune system you can keep
these viruses in remission I think
that's really the key but there's also
one more thing if you also practice
fasting anyone who has Alzheimer's must
be doing intermittent fasting one meal a
day not two meals but one meal a day why
because you need the a good amount of
fasting to put your body into an
autophagy situation autophagy is where
your body is cleaning house it's
cleaning up old dead proteins
it's also strengthening your immune
system it's also bringing your
inflammation down in your brain
it's also going to help increase your
resistance to pathogens and on that note
I have a great video on epigenetics
right here check it out